in this video i'm going to show you how
you can copy and paste using the
evernote app
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs welcome to another
technology tuesday
today i'm answering a question from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
love madrid who wrote in to say how do
you copy and paste
on the app phone of course thanks so the
way you copy and paste in evernote
is the exact same way that you would
copy and paste on your phone
on your tablet or on your computer i'll
show you a few examples
so let's say i wanted to pull a donald
trump quote into my evernote i could do
a search for donald trump quotes
find one that i like so the way to do it
on an android device
is to click on the words that you want
to highlight stretch it out
so if that's the quote i want to copy
then at the top there's a little copy
icon
this one here then i'm going to shoot
over to my evernote
find my note on donald
wherever trump want to add it in i'll
hold again
and then go paste and there's the text
that i had
if you use an apple product i've got my
ipad here do the same thing or do a
search
find the quote i would click on the
quote that i like click and hold
and then move the lines to whatever i
wanted click
copy go to my evernote
see it's already been updated with the
other one and then click and hold
and paste there it is and of course if
you're using a desktop or a laptop
you would copy and paste the same way
that you normally copy and paste on that
computer or desktop so hope that answers
your question thank you so much for
watching
if you guys like this video and you have
other evernote questions you can leave
it in the comments below and i'll try to
make a video response
if you like this video and you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the newsletter and to the channel
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and i'll see you soon